en fait j'étais la première à avoir ça
j'avais déjà entendu parler un peu de
cette pratique là mais c'était un peu il
y a un peu longtemps et ça avait pas
pris une ampleur phénoménale et il y a
pas longtemps en fait je suis sortie
dans le il y avait une un événement à
l'hippodrome de Longchamp quelque chose
comme ça et on avait été du coup avec
des amis donc il y a pas mal de monde
etc et vient le moment en fait on se dit
qu'on va changer d'endroit et on décide
de partir dans le 12e donc on part et on
traverse en fait à ce moment-là la foule
donc il y a vraiment plein de gens etc
et en arrivant en fait de devant
l'hippodrome en attendant le uber je
reçois une première notification sur mon
téléphone je prête pas trop attention
c'est une notification qui me disait que
j'avais un air tag qui était détecté sur
moi enfin qui était détecté voilà c'est
celle-ci qui est détecté à proximité que
l'objet est peut-être sur moi et qu'elle
peut voir ma position donc moi sur le
moment je prête pas trop attention parce
que je me dis bon je suis peut-être
passer à côté de quelqu'un qui avait un
air tag sur lui
je panique pas en fait
c'est une balise 27 euros petite balise
très petite c'est cette taille là que
l'on peut dissimuler c'est ça et les
parents sont servent aussi pour savoir
où sont leurs enfants sert à détecter
effectivement ou à protéger ses biens
aussi c'est très bien matériel à la base
à la base c'est une invention incroyable
absolument bien sûr
incroyable il y a des abrutis servent à
des à des fins harcèlement harcèlement
aux États-Unis il y a eu des cas il fait
divers terrible et puis là maintenant ça
arrive en France c'est-à-dire que des
gens s'en servent pour effectivement
pister notamment des jeunes femmes voilà
alors donc là vous voyez cette
notification vous dites bon je prête pas
3 ans à côté de quelqu'un qui en avait
un
en fait c'est un truc de détraqué enfin
on ne pense pas à ça directement en fait
et au final donc on monte dans le uber
on fait plein de kilomètres du 16e au
12e et arriver là-bas je reçois une
nouvelle notification qui me dit que
c'est toujours sur moi que ça peut
toujours dans ma position et bah que tu
envoies ça je comprends rien l'iPhone
c'est cette journée
[Rires]
quand tu l'as appelé toi ça te fait une
notification sur ton tel pour dire que
tu as cet objectif qui voilà qui elle
est coupée en fait ton GPS en fait si tu
veux donc tu as la position de la balise
tout le temps tu sais que tu es pisté
que tu as un truc
seulement mais non en fait je t'explique
je pense qu'il y a plein de gens qui se
posent la même question que moi parce
qu'on vient on vient de le dire en fait
avec qui c'est très simple c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des parents qui peuvent le
donner à leurs enfants pour savoir où
ils sont trop mais c'est exactement ça
mais en fait il y a des gars ils
achètent ça ils le mettent par exemple
dans ton sac voilà c'est ce qui s'est
passé il le jette dans ton sac pour
pouvoir la fister pour suivre la
personne c'est ça voilà donc comme ça
c'est plus clair et voilà donc quoi si
c'est passé c'est que le mec avait mis
donc le r tag dans ton sac et donc il a
plus de pister surtout le moment en fait
jusqu'au moment où je me rends compte
arriver dans le 12e où je me suis dit
que c'est vraiment pas normal d'avoir
une deuxième notification et du coup bah
là gros mouvement de panique du coup
parce que c'est enfin je me dis qu'il y
a un inconnu que je connais pas qui peut
me tracer mon chemin tout de suite tu as
pensé à ça à la deuxième explication oui
à la première notifications
la deuxième je me suis dit bon ce qu'on
a quand même tracé enfin pas mal de
kilomètres quoi du coup donc j'ouvre en
fait la notification cette deuxième
notification je l'ouvre et ça m'emmène
en fait dans l'application localisée
sur le téléphone et en fait je peux voir
tout le chemin où l'air tag m'a suivi en
fait donc je vois vraiment
tout le chemin sur lequel ça m'a suivi
donc bah là il y a pas de doute et bah
gros mouvement de panique et je retourne
absolument tout mon sac pour essayer de
m'en débarrasser et je récupère que mes
affaires à moi et voilà et puis après on
part quoi on vous l'avez trouvé
non justement moi personnellement en
fait j'ai tellement eu un mouvement de
panique que j'ai vraiment pris mon sac
et j'ai tout ce que tout tout enlevé
j'ai vérifié qui était pas dans mon
portefeuille et j'ai vraiment juste
repris mes affaires et c'est vrai que
j'aurais dû faire attention quand
j'aurais dû essayer de le retrouver pour
essayer d'après d'engager des poursuites
ou quelque chose mais sur le moment je
voulais juste en fait m'en débarrasser
j'ai pas personnellement moi je n'ai pas
j'ai pas été le récupérer en fait
et après voilà à partir de ce moment là
j'ai plus jamais eu cette notification
sur mon téléphone ça apparaissait plus
dans les objets qui pouvaient ma
position donc je pense que oui je l'ai
je l'ai garé du coup à ce moment sur les
réseaux et Diana et quelques jours plus
tard c'est toi Dian qui a été victime de
cette méthode merci d'être là Diana
raconte-nous comment ça s'est passé pour
toi du coup c'est vrai qu'on en parlait
avec Morgane et bon on avait pris ça un
peu à la légère
et en fait justement quand ça s'est
passé moi je revenais de la salle donc
il était vers 21h 30 comme ça et je
passe par un parc en fait pour rentrer
chez moi et puis là Morgane qui
m'appelle au bout d'un moment je
l'appelle puis pour passer le temps de
l'appel je m'assois sur un banc du parc
donc là il y a un homme qui se rapproche
de moi et en fait j'avais une casquette
et donc le premier contact que j'ai avec
cet homme il est hyper bizarre c'est à
dire qu'en fait il va se pencher pour
voir sous mon visage sous ma casquette
donc là je me dis bon c'est je suis une
femme malheureusement voilà faut comme
tu dis malheureusement tu te rends
compte il y a des abrutis qui font ça
malheureusement quand on est une femme
c'est vrai que notre réalité c'est de se
dire que à chaque fois qu'on quitte
notre domicile on est dans l'espace
public espace public nous appartient pas
c'est un truc de fou parce que c'est
vrai que tu te dis tu es une femme il y
a un mec qui vient
même plus étonné que ça arrive
on est complètement désensibilisé et ça
fait hyper peur parce que du coup on il
y a des choses incroyables qui se
passent si on les bananise du coup ça
pour moi déjà c'est un truc incroyable
je te jure mais un mec qui se penche
pour regarder mon visage mais
moi ça Michèle arrivé de ma vie tu vois
donc pour te dire tu te rends compte ou
pas c'est à dire qu'il y a des les
femmes elles mettent des les mettre une
casquette elle sort tranquille il y a
des non mais il y a des abrutis je te
jure mets-moi même ça ce truc il est
attaque c'est que ça me rend fou moi
j'ai une fille et mecs comme ça tu tu te
dis mais dans tu te dis qu'est-ce que je
vais faire avec un gars comme ça tu
l'attrape tu fais quoi avec un gars
comme ça tu fais quoi de la chance parce
que on avait des iPhone donc on a eu la
notification bien sûr pour toutes les
personnes qui ont pas des iPhone du coup
elles ont pas cette notifications
j'aurais jamais vu si j'avais pas eu un
iPhone quoi alors Diana donc on passe
dans le parc ça c'est le premier combat
que j'ai avec cet homme le deuxième
contact est assez étrange aussi bon
c'est clairement une excuse il arrive
pour me pour me demander l'heure il
avait clairement un téléphone dans les
mains donc voilà
je lui donne l'heure parce que je
cherche pas midi à 14h je veux pas trop
lui parler troisième contact il arrive
derrière moi il se rapproche et je pense
que c'est à ce moment là qu'il a mis le
voilà et donc il se rapproche il me
demande si tout va bien si j'ai besoin
de quelque chose donc implicitement il
me demande si je veux de la drogue donc
moi je lui dis non et là je me dis que
bon il est temps d'y aller donc je
raccroche la peur à ce moment-là quand
même
trois fois il vient me casser ouais et
je me dis que enfin ils vendent la
drogue je sais pas ce qu'il est capable
de faire donc je me dis là le temps de
se lever il y avait que lui et moi dans
le parc il était 21h et en plus j'habite
à côté donc je me lève et donc je vais
chez moi dès que j'arrive chez moi j'ai
même pas le temps de fermer la porte que
je reçois une notification et c'est
justement une notification comme celle
de Morgane c'est justement celle du
screen et c'est vrai que si il y avait
pas eu le truc l'épisode avec Morgane
j'aurais pris ça comme une énième
notification comme comme mon iPhone me
dit qu'il est saturé ou je sais pas
justement
est-ce que je c'est chelou il était
arrivé un truc comme ça je me suis dit
ouh là là et donc j'appuie et là ça fait
hyper peur c'est hyper anxiogène on
arrive sur une page comme ça sur
l'application localisée et moi je n'ai
même pas que mon iphone avait une
application localisée avant et je vois
il y a écrit le propriétaire de cet art
tag peut voir votre localisation en
temps réel et donc là bah je panique
totalement
et je le cherche je le cherche partout
je le trouve pas j'ai une amie qui me
dit regarde dans tes chaussures regarde
je le trouve pas et en fait je retourne
sur l'application localisée et il y a
écrit émettre un son donc bah je le fais
sonner et en fait c'était le bordel dans
mon top bag et je finis par le retrouver
donc je le retrouve et là bah moi je
sais pas quoi faire je vais pas nique
totalement je le jette Morgan me dit
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu en as
fait je lui dis bah je l'ai jeté elle me
dit mais non parce que du coup je l'ai
jeté j'habite au 13e je me dis va se
casser mais en fait la localisation elle
est encore d'actualité ça veut dire que
la personne qui a qui m'a mis le r tag
bah elle peut encore voir que le dernier
point de localisation est devant chez
moi donc je l'ai jeté mais donc à ce
moment là elle me dit bah va le chercher
et tout mais je me dis
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que ça a coupé mais de
ce que j'ai s'il voit lui a dit ouais
qu'est-ce que tu cherches tu cherches
pas une fille et tout qui et là il me
donne ma description et je sais pas
c'est partant altercation lui a mis un
gros coup de pression je crois qu'ils se
sont battus et au final mon frère a
réussi à récupérer le r tag qui était du
coup en bas des fenêtres où je l'avais
jeté et parce qu'en fait on me le passe
et Apple avait prévu que il y ait des
gens qui puissent l'utiliser de manière
malhonnête c'est à dire que quand on va
sur l'application localisée et on a la
notification là en fait en bas en petite
petite écriture il y a écrit si votre
sécurité est mise en jeu est engagée
quoi que ce soit il y a toute une
procédure à effectuer donc en fait ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on enlève la pile de
l'air tag et on le désactive de cette
manière il peut la personne qui nous l'a
mis ne peut plus voir notre localisation
puis nous ça nous fait un hairtag
gilberté avait dit tout à l'heure que
c'était 27 euros et bah c'est 39 39
euros donc ils mettent les moyens pour
si on est dans si on veut vraiment se
mettre dans leurs chaussures tu te dis
j'achète un air tag 39 €, je suis
quelqu'un je lui fais un cambriolage
peut-être que je voilà je fais plus
mais bon après on va pas se mettre dans
leurs chaussures parce que non mais
c'est vrai mais non mais on va pas se
mettre dans le dans les chaussures de de
ces abrutis qui font du coup quand on
désactive la pile il y a on récupère le
numéro de série et Apple a un site de
support et moi personnellement j'ai
énormément de peur de la police donc je
n'irai jamais porter plainte n'importe
quoi je non je j'ai trop peur
de la police dans le sens où
j'ai pas envie de me prendre un dédain
en pleine face j'ai pas envie de ne pas
être cru j'ai pas envie qu'on
décrédibilise que je vais dire parce
qu'en soit qu'est-ce que je vais faire
je vais aller dormir un truc comme ça
oui pour moi et pour d'autres gens que
je connais mais sur des de faire
beaucoup plus grave sur des affaires de
viol etc et là je me enfin je me dis je
vais au commissariat je vais leur dire
quoi on m'a mis ça dans mon sac enfin
plus avoir peur des prédateurs
il a l'adresse donc c'est ça le truc
c'est que Apple a vraiment un bon truc
c'est que enfin bon truc sur le site
alors je supporte quand on entre le
numéro de série qu'on a récupéré et une
fois qu'ils ont le numéro de série c'est
eux qui se charge de de ça va très bien
ça va et toi
mais du coup
il se charge eux-mêmes de contacter le
personnels
d'accord
est-ce que du coup ils ont grâce au
numéro de série qui a acheté et ils vont
dire à la cette personne utilise
des manières sur un plateau pour en
parler parce que
voilà je voudrais dire et Morgan merci
d'être là parce que je te jure ça c'est
un truc tu l'aurais pas mis je te jure
et à chaque fois la technologie en fait
la technologie ça engendre des des oufs
non mais je te jure que c'est vrai il y
a des études qui sont sortis c'est 50%
de harceleur dans les utilisations
frauduleuses et 50% de Marie jaloux
compagnon jaloux ou ex jaloux toxique et
comme quoi les réseaux sociaux et toutes
ces nouvelles technologies qui sont très
utiles d'un côté ça engendrer ceux qui
sont déjà tordu dans leur esprit mais
non mais le problème tu auras toujours
ça je t'explique toutes les toutes les
innovations ont engendré des débit
tordus des mecs qui vont dire on va
servir de ça faut le problème c'est les
tordu je suis désolé mais tu vas pas tu
vas pas dans leur vie en fait les mecs
les mecs tu vas pas les empêcher de
faire des innovations des trucs qui qui
servent moi je te dis ça pour les mecs
que les gens qui ont des enfants qui
mettent ça ils sont ils sont rassurés
ils savent ils tu vois dans le sac à dos
ils ont chacun une montre avec une
balise je sais un mètre près où ils sont
quoi
rassurant sur mon scooter aussi ça c'est
un super c'est un super bail j'adore
bien sûr mais le truc c'est que tu as
toujours des abrutis des ouf elle est
oufs
toujours les trucs bien pour en faire
des les les les les les les les les des
trucs de de de de de de de voilà de
dégénérer ah oui
parce que la probabilité que ça leur
soit arrivé à toutes les deux bien sûr
c'est parce que si c'est quand même une
dinguerie
donc il va falloir
c'est que on était en fait on était plus
en sécurité dans la rue et maintenant on
est même plus en sécurité chez nous
parce que là ils ont notre adresse donc
toi dans tout le monde d'immeuble
comment tu es en ce moment tu t'es en
angoisse tu en restera ou ça va bah moi
j'ai juste la haine vraiment je te
comprends c'est la non mais je te jure
je comprends c'est un supportable c'est
quoi ça
les abrutis qu'il y a non mais
c'est même des prédateurs et même des
prédateurs dangereux qu'il y a des mecs
je pense que quand on est une femme du
coup et qu'on a vécu ce genre de choses
et qu'on se dit à chaque fois qu'on va
sortir bon il va se passer un truc et
c'est vraiment la façon dont je vais
juste blasé genre juste la haine et je
suis blasé je suis même pas traumatisée
je suis même pas tellement c'est je sais
que c'est récurrent et que ça va
sûrement encore arriver je me dis ça m'a
choqué dès le début quand tu m'as dit tu
étais même pas étonné qu'il y a un gars
et qu'une casquette tu es un gars qui
vient regarder en dessous et ce qui
ferait ça un mec qui va prendre une
tarte dans la gueule non mais je te jure
que c'est vrai c'est insupportable
d'entendre ça je te dis la vérité on a
l'impression que les hommes enfin c'est
tout permis
parce que même si on porte plainte même
si on fait quoi que ce soit ça changera
jamais rien d'accord j'ai ramené le air
tag parce qu'on m'avait dit si c'était
mieux de le ramener et c'est vraiment
hyper petit
ça ressemble à ça
en tout cas Tania et Morgan merci
d'avoir été là toutes les deux et on
espère on a eu Diana parce que Tania est
parti
excuse-moi Diana Morgan et Diana merci
d'avoir été là et franchement je vous
dis j'espère que ça va servir parce que
ça c'est un vraiment c'est chaud je vous
dis c'est très chaud
j'ai regardé un petit peu les les
réactions qu'il y avait par rapport au
sud que j'avais fait et il y avait
vraiment pas mal de personnes de femmes
qui disaient que elles avaient déjà eu
cette notification là mais qu'elles
avaient pas prêté attention ou même
qu'elle savait pas ce que c'était je te
dis là passer des trucs grave et que au
contraire ce que le fait que vous venez
ce soir peut-être que ça va décompter
des choses et qu'il y a des gens qui
vont qui vont parler et qui vont qui
vont dire ils vont dire des choses